the first challenge for mps today could
they get to the office the house of
commons there was much heavier police
presence around west block mps returned
not only to get back to the people's
business but for the symbolic importance
i think it is important in the democracy
to show that we would be there folks
like this
are not going to stop me from doing my
job
but it was a nervous time for some mps
navigating through crowds that have been
raucous it's worrying to come into work
i had to walk in with my staff and i was
worried about them i was worried about
you know safety of people that are
coming to the hill to do their jobs the
prime minister was not in he now has
covid along with his two children so is
isolating i feel well and have no
symptoms but his message to protesters
in circling parliament was blunt we are
not
intimidated
by those who hurl insults and abuse
there is always a right
to protest peacefully that i and others
will defend fully as part of this
democracy
there is not a right
to incite violence
to perform acts of violence the
honorable leader of the opposition the
chamber where canada's political
differences are hashed out did resume
without disruption the opposition
leader's first question would the pm
meet with specific protesters namely the
truckers who want border vaccine
mandates dropped will the prime minister
move past the division and agree to meet
with some of the truckers impacted by
his federal regulations but trudeau had
made clear he would not meet with the
protesters and he will not back off
vaccine mandates the best way through
this pandemic is to get people
vaccinated that's how we end the
disruptions to our supply chains caused
by this global pandemic
one conservative mp was happy to address
demonstrators not supporting those with
extreme views but those fed up with the
restrictions i'm a supporter of of what
their message is and that's freedoms and
and the mandates anti-vax canadians and
those opposed to all mandates represent
just a small percentage of the country
in political terms the government has
seldom found itself with an issue so
one-sided an issue this liberal
government is quite comfortable debating
eric sorensen global news ottawa